hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live die energie ist teuer die Zinsen
hoch und auch der Export läuft nur
schwach das merken wir alle und unsere
Wirtschaft quer durch alle Branchen die
tritt auf der Stelle woran liegt das
eben nicht nur an globalen Umständen
nein sondern wir haben eben auch
Probleme in unserem eigenen Land die die
Wirtschaft Schwächen zu lange
Genehmigungsverfahren z.B
Fachkräftemangel zu viel Bürokratie zu
wenig digital die Liste ist lang und
macht uns allen Sorgen
Wirtschaftskrise tut die Ampel zu wenig
das ist heute unser Thema diese Frage
wollen wir mit euch diskutieren und wir
wollen vor allem das ist der anders auch
live schalten zur Pressekonferenz der
Regierung die wollen wir gemeinsam mit
euch verfolgen denn die tritt sie trifft
sich aktuell zur Kabinettsklausur in
Meseberg wir sehen hier erste Bilder die
sind schon gestern zusammengekommen und
sie will ein Paket auf den Weg bringen
um Wirtschaft und Wachstum zu stärken so
heißt es ob das reicht kommentiert mit
dem Stream oder schreibt uns eine Mail
wir werden das Ganze live für euch
verfolgen analysieren einordnen seid
gerne mit dabei und bevor es losgeht ich
habe das für euch im Auge und wir gehen
wie gesagt live drauf zur
Pressekonferenz haben wir hoffentlich
noch ein bisschen Zeit können jetzt
zuerst mal sprechen mit unserem
Hauptstadtstudio Korrespondenten mit
Dominik schöpker der bei mir ist hallo
Dominik hallo Alisa grüß Dich Dominik
ich habe es angekündigt wir erwarten
eine Pressekonferenz können wir da aber
eben auch gleich ganz konkrete Antworten
erwarten von dieser Regierung die sich
wirklich in den letzten Wochen Monaten
bei mir quasi keinem Thema einig war die
Bundesregierung seit Jahren es wird
konkrete Maßnahmen geben zum Beispiel
das wachstumschancengesetz zu den
Christian Lindner ja auch gestern schon
ein paar Worte gesagt hat es wird
außerdem ein Eckpunktepapier
verabschiedet in Richtung Bürokratie
Abbau von Justizminister Marco Buschmann
die elektronische Patientenakte wird ein
Thema sein von Karl Lauterbach das sind
jetzt nicht ganz neue Ideen und ganz
neue Maßnahmen aber die Regierung will
glaube ich diese Klausur schon dafür
nutzen um das symbolische Neustart Bild
zu setzen nach dem vielen Streit soll
jetzt Einigkeit demonstriert werden
Einigkeit und wir sehen auch die drei
schon es geht pünktlicher los als wir
dachten wir werden jetzt also gleich
dann direkt zur Pressekonferenz Schalten
mit dem Bundeskanzler dem
Wirtschaftsminister und unserem
Energieminister und danach wieder mit
dir sprechen Dominik für uns ein und
jetzt hören wir erstmal zu
einen schönen guten Tag wir haben heute
mit der Kabinettssitzung die Klausur
unsere skabinetts in Meseberg beendet
auf dieser Kabinettssitzung haben wir
wie schon zuvor in dieser Klausur
Zusammenkunft viele wichtige Fragen für
die Zukunft unseres Landes besprochen
jetzt das Thema ist wirtschaftliches
Wachstum das ist auch jetzt ganz konkret
geworden mit dem Beschluss über das
wachstumsschancengesetz das wir den wir
gefasst haben der eine umfassende
Entlastung für die Wirtschaft enthält
und Investitionen anregen soll wir haben
eine Situation in der das Wachstum nicht
so stark ist wie wir uns das wünschen
deshalb wollen wir mit diesen Maßnahmen
auch dazu beitragen dass es ein größeres
Wachstum gibt und dass wir die
Unternehmen dazu ermutigen jetzt
Investitionen zu tätigen um das möglich
zu machen zweites großes Thema unser
Beratung und Zusammenkunft ist der
Bürokratieabbau auch das hat heute
sowohl in der Klausur als auch während
der Kabinettssitzung eine Rolle gespielt
wo wir dann unsere entsprechenden
Beschlüsse Bürokratieabbau und zur
Entlastung der Wirtschaft in dieser
Frage gefasst haben wir werden aber bei
diesem Thema weiter dran bleiben denn
tatsächlich haben wir schon im letzten
und diesem wir eine ganze Reihe von
Entscheidungen getroffen die viele
Genehmigungsprozesse beschleunigt haben
nun setzen wir das Fort mit den heutigen
Beschlüssen aber wir hören nicht auf wir
brauchen ein großes deutschlandtempo bei
Genehmigung und wir brauchen eine
Entlastung von unnötigen bürokratischen
Prozeduren und das dritte ist die Frage
der Digitalisierung wir haben sehr
umfassend während unser Gespräche
gestern über künstliche Intelligenz
diskutiert heute haben wir sehr zentrale
Entscheidung vorangebracht was die
Digitalisierung betrifft einmal Gesetze
die sich mit Daten fragen im
Gesundheitswesen beschäftigen da geht es
ganz besonders darum dass wir möglich
machen dass die Forschung in Deutschland
voran kommt in dem Daten genutzt werden
können das gilt auch für die
datenstrategie die die Bundesregierung
festgelegt hat also drei wichtige
entscheidungskomplex bei denen es um die
Modernisierung unseres Landes die
Beförderung des Wirtschaftswachstums
geht und genau das was jetzt in dieser
Situation notwendig ist vielleicht noch
eine Bemerkung zum Schluss wir haben mit
dieser und den beiden Sitzungen des
Kabinetts zuvor in den letzten Wochen
sehr viele sehr zahlreiche Beschlüsse
auf den Weg gebracht viele
Gesetzesvorhaben die Sommerpause war für
die Regierung produktiv und das
Parlament und die gesetzgebenden
Körperschaften unseres Landes haben
jetzt viel zu tun das ist aber gut so
vielen Dank anknüpfen dann lass was der
Herr Bundeskanzler gerade gesagt hat
würde ich gerne mit einem mit einer
Runde die wir gestern Abend gedreht
haben einsetzen wo wir einmal den Blick
geweitet haben und nicht über die vielen
einzelnen Gesetze in
bürokratisierungsvorschriften gesprochen
haben sondern versucht haben den Blick
aufs Ganze zu heben mit einem
Gastreferenten und mein meine Konsequenz
daraus ist und ich glaube die hat sich
dann in vielen Tischgesprächen wieder
gespiegelt ist das eine
gesellschaftsziele und Optimismus
braucht diese Ziele auch erreichen zu
können passiert das nicht wächst der
Zweifel und aus Zweifel entsteht Angst
und aus Angstmacherei und dann kassiert
der Populismus der ja im Kern eine nicht
Lösung Politik ist sondern nur versucht
die Krisen zu verschaffen und daraus
politisches Kapital zu schlagen und es
ist so dass wir in Zeiten leben wo man
sich Sorgen machen kann wo eine gewisse
Erschöpfung eine krisenerschöpfung
eingetreten ist nach der Pandemie dem
fürchterlichen noch fortwährenden linkes
Krieg Russlands auf die Ukraine und den
damit verbundenen Turbulenzen aber auch
insgesamt dem großen Druck den wir
spüren und den wir auch umsetzen müssen
schneller zu werden mit allem möglichen
der Transformation hin zu
Klimaneutralität dem Wettlauf bei
digitalen Techniken dem globalen
Wettlauf insgesamt also es ist schon
sehr viel los und der Druck auf
Gesellschaft und auf Politik ist
insgesamt natürlich sehr sehr hoch die
Aufgabe dieser Regierung und das hat
glaube ich diese Tagung noch mal
besonders ausgemacht ist zu verstehen
dass verschiedene Blickwinkel eine
Stärke sind dass man voneinander lernen
kann und das Kompromisse was Gutes sind
um die Mitte und die Handlungsfähigkeit
stabil zu halten
und diese Geschlossenheit die er nicht
eine statische ist sondern eine lernende
Geschlossenheit die ins Zentrum zu
stellen dass sicherlich ist der Geist
dieser Klausur gewesen und hat sich
wiedergespiegelt in bestimmten und
verschiedenen Beschlüssen heute
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat das
angesprochen gestern haben wir ihn schon
ein paar Punkte zu dem
wachstumschancengesetz vorgestellt das
heißt also die Wirtschaftspolitik in den
Mittelpunkt stellt heute hat die
Entbürokratisierung oder ich würde
anders positiver formulieren der moderne
Staat weite Räume eingenommen und da
haben viele Ministerien
zusammengearbeitet das Innenministerium
sozialdemokratisch geführt dass
Justizministerium mit tätiger Hilfe des
Finanzministeriums liberal geführt und
auch mein Haus bzw das Umweltministerium
ich will ohne jetzt die ganze Herleitung
noch mal wieder zu geben nur darauf
hinweisen dass wir verschiedene
Instrumente identifiziert und auch haben
und auch umsetzen die davor noch nicht
da waren sogenannte praxis-checks also
nicht aus der Verwaltung heraus zu sagen
eigentlich besser geht sondern in die
Betriebe in die Unternehmen reinzugehen
den über die Schulter zu schauen und
daraus abzuleiten wo man Dinge bündeln
kann auch sein lassen kann das haben wir
schon sehr erfolgreich durchgeführt
beispielsweise bei Smart Meter Roll-Out
bei
solargenehmigung und das werden wir
weiter in Einwanderen Bereichen
fortführen
reallabore und experimentierräume zu
schaffen ist eine gute Möglichkeit also
einfach mal Dinge auf den Weg bringen
und danach erst schauen ob sie wirklich
so gefährlich und so schlimm sind wie
man das gedacht hat und dann drittens
und das hat der Kollege gemacht heute
sehr stark vorangebracht europäisch auf
der europäischen Ebene zu schauen dass
wir die Regulierungsdichte etwas lichten
insofern glaube ich atmosphärisch wie
inhaltlich eine sehr sehr gute Tagung
da möchte ich mich gerne anschließen es
war eine gute Klausurtagung hier in
Meseberg zum einen hatten wir eine
inspirierende
Diskussion zum Thema künstliche
Intelligenz mit unseren Gästen einer
ohne Zweifel
grundlegende industrielle Revolution in
der wir
gegenwärtig schon im
werden sind die wir gestalten wollen das
ist sich positiv für unser Land
entwickelt und zum anderen haben wir
gute Beschlüsse gefasst
wir sind eine Regierung wo
gehämmert geschraubt wird das führt zu
Geräuschen wie sie schon festgestellt
haben aber es kommt eben auch was raus
der Bundeskanzler hat darauf hingewiesen
dass das was wir uns vorgenommen haben
für die sitzungsfreizeit des Bundestages
an gesetzgebungsinitiativen dass wir die
auch abgeschlossen haben
ich will hier insbesondere auch
unterstreichen dass wir mit dem
wachstumsschancengesetz und mit der
Initiative zum Abbau von
Bürokratielasten ja auch ein
übergreifendes Signal senden sind nicht
nur sieben Milliarden Euro Impulse für
das wirtschaftliche Wachstum und 2,3
Milliarden Euro weniger
erfüllungsaufwand für bürokratische
Vorgaben das ist ja die Technik aber das
übergreifende politische Signal ist
diese Regierung kennt die Lage im Land
die Regierung kennt die Situation der
Wirtschaft und sie reagiert sie handelt
im übrigen handeln wir auch agil die man
der Tatsache entnehmen konnte dass das
wachstumschancengesetz ja anders jetzt
auch in der Architektur ist als noch vor
einigen Monaten auch geplant die
degressive AfA auf geringwertige
Wirtschaftsgüter ab 1 oktober kommt
beispielsweise dazu also ein breiter
Impuls in die Wirtschaft degressive AfA
von 6 % für den Wohnungsbau da sehen wir
diese Situation hat sich erschwert und
wir reagieren also die Regierung kennt
die Lage sie handelt und sie ist dabei
auch agil und kann sich anpassen an
andere Erfordernisse das doch eine gute
Botschaft
viele Fragen die erste Frage hat Michael
Fischer
ja vielen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler das
Kabinett hat eine ganze Reihe von
Maßnahmen zur Förderung des
Wirtschaftswachstums heute beschlossen
was sie noch nicht entschieden haben
hier in Meseberg ist wie die Unternehmen
von den hohen Energiekosten entlastet
werden sollen ihre Fraktion hat am
Montag ein Konzept für ein
industriestrompreis ein befristeten
industriestrompreis beschlossen sie
haben die Klausurtagung vor der
Entscheidung verlassen stehen Sie als
SPD-Abgeordneter und als Bundeskanzler
hinter diesem Konzept und
Herr Minister Lindner sie haben den
industriestrompreis ja jetzt schon
mehrfach abgelehnt gestern in einem
Interview auch wieder ist das ein
kategorisches nein also sind sie nicht
bereit darüber mit den
Koalitionspartnern zu verhandeln und ist
die Senkung der Stromsteuer jetzt quasi
dagegen Vorschlag der FDP
wir haben uns wie sie ja eben von uns
dreien gehört haben und auch Ihren
Unterlagen entnehmen können mit dem mit
der Förderung der Wirtschaft beschäftigt
den wachsen chancengesetz vorher ja
schon dem zukunftsfinanzierungsgesetz
dass wir nicht in dieser Woche aber
vorher bereits auf den Weg gebracht
hatten und natürlich vielen weiteren
Maßnahmen die dazu beitragen dass unsere
Wirtschaft voran kommt die Frage der
Sicherung einer billigen
Energieversorgung ist ein Dauerthema der
Regierung wir haben ja schon vor dem
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
begonnen darüber nachzudenken was
passiert wenn die gastversorgung die
Energieversorgung Deutschlands mit
fossiler Energie gefährdet ist und die
Tatsache dass wir da so früh und
zeitlich gehandelt haben hat dazu
beigetragen dass wir
durch den Winter gekommen sind dass es
nicht kalt geworden ist in den Wohnungen
und den Fabriken dass die Wirtschaft
weiter agieren konnte und wir haben dazu
sehr viel Geld in die Hand genommen um
das zu subventionieren was im
Preissteigerung zwischendurch überall zu
spüren war da ging es um viele viele
Milliarden jetzt sehen wir dass die
Preise fallen gerade heute wieder sind
Meldung für uns alle lesbar gewesen dass
das auch durchschlägt mittlerweile auf
Preise für Unternehmen und für
Verbrauchern Verbraucher dass die
Importkosten für Deutschland insgesamt
sinken das ist ein Teil der einen
Ergebnis der Strategie die wir
entwickelt haben und zu unserer
Strategie gehört auch strukturell dafür
zu sorgen dass wir geringe Stromkosten
in Deutschland haben indem wir mit noch
neuem Tempo die erneuerbaren Energien
ausbauen die sind die Garantie dafür ein
leistungsfähiges übertragungsstromnetz
ein
umfassender Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien
garantiert Deutschland auch im
Wettbewerb gute Preise für Strom und für
Energie und gerade für Strom ist das
deshalb so wichtig weil das ja im Rahmen
der dekarbonisierung unserer Wirtschaft
auch zu einer erheblichen Ausweitung der
Stromnutzung kommen wird und wir deshalb
mehr Strom brauchen den auch billig
Konsequenz hat das für den Netzausbau
auch da sind wir mit den Gesetzen
vorangekommen und jetzt werden sehr
viele Genehmigung und kurzer Zeit
erfolgen die viel später anstanden noch
in der letzten Legislaturperiode als wir
sie jetzt angreifen können auch das hat
unmittelbare Folgen für die Strompreise
nur noch mal dieser Hinweis gegenwärtig
müssen wir Geld dafür ausgeben dass
Strom nicht produziert wird der im
Norden Osten Deutschlands produziert
werden konnte mit Windkraft und dann
müssen wir Geld ausgeben um ihn dann mit
Gas oder Kohle im Südwesten der Republik
zu produzieren damit er dort eingesetzt
werden kann werden die Leitung schon
fertig würden uns zweimal diese Kosten
sparen und hätten die strukturellen
Vorteile die aus dem Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien schon da ansonsten
ist es so dass wir wissen dass jetzt
auch andere sich mit der Frage
beschäftigen wie man dazu beitragen kann
dass unsere Wirtschaft gute Bedingungen
vorfindet das ist immer den Schweiß der
edlen Wert deshalb freuen wir uns dass
unsere Bemühungen die Sie jetzt hier
präsentiert bekommen haben auch von
vielen Gedanken die andere haben mit
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven begleitet
werden aber das ist eine Debatte die
erstmal dort stattfindet und wo wir
gerne hinschauen und uns vor allem
darüber freuen dass das Interesse
Wirtschaft Aktivierung zu betreiben ein
allseitiges ist
die Vorschläge der Bundesregierung sind
ihnen bekannt und dass wir heute gemacht
haben und das Konzept das wir verfolgen
habe ich auch erläutert
ich kann mich dem Bundeskanzler nur in
allen Punkten anschließen
ja vielen Dank ich erlaube mir die Frage
vom letzten Mal noch mal zu stellen Herr
Lindner wie ist der Stand der
technischen Vorbereitungen beim
klimagergeld und an alle gefragt nachdem
das Geld ja über den klimatransformation
wenn ich es richtig sehe bis zum Jahr
2027 schon für andere Projekte verplant
ist gibt's das Geld überhaupt noch und
was heißt das für die Akzeptanz von
Klimapolitik insgesamt wenn man den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern sagt die in den
kommenden Jahren ja stark steigenden CO2
Abgaben das Geld bekommt ihr nicht auf
anderen Wegen zurück sondern wir
subventionieren damit beispielsweise
Chip Fabriken danke schön
wir haben die gesetzlichen Grundlagen ja
sehr rasch geschaffen für einen solchen
auszahlungsmechanismus des klimageldes
und jetzt arbeitet die Verwaltung mit
Hochdruck daran die technischen
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen und die
Daten zu organisieren wenn sie mal
vielleicht mit dem Management Ihres
Verlages sprechen die Beschaffung und
die Aktualisierung von Abonnenten und
Abonnenten Daten das ist auch eine
mühevolle Aufgabe wir schaffen jetzt
erst einmal eine Datenbank und zwar
nicht nur die IT sondern auch den Inhalt
IBAN und Steueridentifikationsnummer
zusammenzubringen ich gehe davon aus
dass dieser auszahlungsmechanismus 2024
zur Verfügung steht und damit wenn es
richtig sehe Robert deutlich schneller
als wir im Koalitionsvertrag in Erwägung
gezogen haben ein solches Klima Geld
auszuzahlen und für die öffentliche
Verwaltung ist es ebenfalls relativ
hohes Tempo ein solches Instrument dass
es nicht vorher gab technisch zu
ermöglichen und die Daten zu sammeln
vielleicht darf ich folgendes ergänzen
wir haben uns für diese
Legislaturperiode anders als die
insinuieren vorgenommen dass wir die
technischen Möglichkeiten solche
Zahlungen zu leisten schaffen weil in
den Debatten die wir früher geführt
haben waren es immer die vielen Jahre
die man braucht bis man die technische
Möglichkeit hat die dazu geführt haben
dass wir das Instrument im Rahmen einer
konkreten politischen Initiative
verworfen haben und jetzt drehen wir das
um wir schaffen erstmal ganz
abstrakt die technische Möglichkeit die
wir dann in den nächsten Jahren bei z.B
auch Wirtschaftskrisen oder anderen
Fällen einsetzen können wenn sie sehen
wie wir bestimmte corona-hilfen den
Bürgern und Bürgern haben zukommen
lassen dann war das auch nicht ganz
einfach wir mussten immer Umwege wählen
wir hatten den Weg direkt Überweisung an
alle nicht zur Hand und diese technische
Möglichkeit schaffen wir jetzt das ist
eher geizig und darum kümmern wir uns
ansonsten will ich darauf hinweisen dass
wir im Augenblick eine Negativbilanz
haben denn wir haben ja
die
EEG-Umlage also die Umlage auf die über
den Strompreis finanziert worden ist für
die erneuerbaren Energien abgeschafft
sie wird nicht mehr erhoben das ist ein
Gesamtvolumen von 20 Milliarden und die
Einnahmen aus der CO2 Bepreisung haben
diese Größenordnung noch nicht erreicht
also die Bürger sind entlastet worden
bevor wir die Einnahmen hatten
Herbeck ich würde ganz gerne nochmal auf
den industriestrompreis zurückkommen
kritiker sagen dass das eigentlich eine
scheinde Debatte sei weil die
EU-Kommission einen solchen einer
solchen Subventionierung ohnehin nicht
zustimmen würde deswegen hätte ich von
ihnen ganz gerne eine Einschätzung haben
sie schon mit der EU-Kommission
gesprochen glauben Sie dass die
EU-Kommission überhaupt zustimmen würde
und Herr Lindner zu dem Wachstumschancen
gesetzt dass sie eben hervorgehoben
haben die müssen ja auch noch die
Bundesländer zustimmen die genauso wie
die Kommunen erheblichen Teil der Kosten
tragen müssen sind sie überhaupt
zuversichtlich dass die Länderkammer
hier zustimmt oder droht hier dieses
Paket noch mal besser zu werden
Bundeskanzlerin gesagt aber natürlich
gibt es Gespräche mit der EU-Kommission
die gibt es sowieso permanent und auch
über den Industrie und Preis wurde immer
wieder gesprochen oder eine Problematik
hier offensichtlich ist das nämlich in
Europa die Industrie
wettbewerbsfähig produzieren muss also
natürlich gibt es da ein fortwährenden
gesprächskanal und
mir ist jetzt nicht zu sagen heute
jedenfalls nicht
wir haben jetzt einen Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung beschlossen und der geht
jetzt in das Beratungsverfahren des
Deutschen Bundestages und beim Bundesrat
sowohl Parlament als auch Länderkammer
können selbstverständlich da auch noch
Änderungen einbringen so ist das in der
föderal verfassten parlamentarischen
Demokratie unseres Landes
ich höre das manche unter den Ländern
sich noch mehr vorstellen können und
noch mehr fordern andere haben bei
bestimmten Maßnahmen eine Skepsis zu
Protokoll gegeben das werden wir sehen
betrifft im übrigen das
wachstumschancengesetz genauso wie die
Kinder Grundsicherung und ich hatte bei
der Vorstellung der Kindergrundsicherung
gesagt dass wir sehr genau zuhören wenn
Länder und Kommunen sich einbringen und
das gilt in gleicher Weise auch für das
wachstumschancengesetz ein Punkt möchte
ich aber machen nämlich den dass Länder
und Gemeinden genauso wie der Bund ein
Interesse daran haben müssen die
wirtschaftliche Stärke unseres Landes zu
sichern die Einnahme Basis von Bund
Ländern und Gemeinden zu sichern dadurch
dass wir unsere Wirtschaft ein Impuls
geben das gewissermaßen eine Investition
auch in zukünftig eine starke Einnahme
Basis dieses Gemeinwesens
Herr Bundeskanzler haben Sie auf dieser
Klausur auch über geopolitische Fragen
gesprochen zum Beispiel wie Deutschland
sich davor schützen will dass die von
Auswirkungen einer jetzt auch
schwächelnden chinesischen Wirtschaft
und aber auch fragen wie die Lage in der
sahelregion und dann Herr Lindner sie
hatten davon gesprochen dass gehämmert
und geklopft wird ich hoffe ihr geht sie
da richtig wieder gleichzeitig Herr
Bundeskanzler hat ihre Partei sie dazu
aufgerufen als kabinettgeräuschlos zu
arbeiten also muss man sich jetzt an
Hermann und klopfen gewöhnen oder haben
sie Geräuschlosigkeit womöglich auch für
einen bestimmten Zeitraum für einbart
wir werden Hämmern und Klopfen aber mit
schalte Dämpfer also da wird dann doch
das soll ja nicht mehr gehört werden
doch so dass wir das alles kennen ich
habe schon vielen Regierung in
Deutschland angehört als Arbeitsminister
und als Finanzminister und auch selber
eine Regierung in
einem der letzten Länder geführt und
immer hat das Diskussion gegeben manche
haben sich auch sehr lange
zugetragen aber am Ende müssen
Entscheidungen stehen und gut ist wenn
dieser Prozess des Arbeitens erstens
aktiv ist und man sich nicht vor den
Aufgaben drückt das ist glaube ich an
wirklicher Vorzug der jetzigen Regierung
dass wir viel liegen genügendes
abarbeiten dass wir dafür sorgen dass
Dinge Vorankommen die in Deutschland
nicht vorangekommen waren zum Beispiel
dem Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
aber es ist dann so dass wir schon uns
vorgenommen haben dass das
geräuschloser stattfindet und dazu haben
wir den technische Möglichkeiten wo das
Hämmern und Klopfen stattfindet aber
weniger laut bei Ihnen ankommt was die
anderen Fragen betrifft natürlich haben
wir die Gelegenheit genutzt viele Fragen
zu diskutieren dazu dient ja auch so ein
eine Zusammenkunft hier die auch
informell Gespräche ermöglicht für die
Frage der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung
ist natürlich klar dass die Tatsache
dass Deutschland eine Exportwirtschaft
ist und eine Exportwirtschaft bleiben
soll dass wir die Stärke unserer
Volkswirtschaft im hohen Maße
erfolgreich zu sein auf globalen Märkten
nicht in Frage stellen wenn dann gerade
in der Weltwirtschaft eine Schwächephase
in der ein oder anderen Region ist die
wir dann natürlich auch merken aber wir
können natürlich keinen
Konjunkturprogramm in China aus
Deutschland heraus starten sondern wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass unsere
Unternehmen die gesamte Weltwirtschaft
im Blick nehmen damit sie überall Export
wirkte haben das ist auch das was real
geschieht und dass die stabil und robust
ist eine solche Situation auch
durchzustehen damit sie dabei ist wenn
es wieder losgeht und dafür gibt's ja
auch Anzeichen dass das irgendwann auch
wieder der Fall sein wird und dann
unsere Stärke als Exportnationen wieder
allseits gefeiert wird und zwar zu Recht
Herr Bundeskanzler rechnen sie noch mit
dem grünen Wirtschaftswunder in dieser
Legislaturperiode und ähm Weg legen Sie
den industriestrompreis eigentlich jetzt
er attackter oder glauben Sie wenn sich
die Konjunkturdaten in diesem Jahr noch
weiter verschlechtern dass das noch mal
auf die Tagesordnung kommt danke
ich gehe fest davon aus dass die der
Umbau unser Volkswirtschaft sich auch in
einem großen Wachstum niederschlagen
wird das werden wir auch entsprechend
sehen und spüren und das kann man ja
auch ausrechnen was das bedeutet wenn
wir und dafür spricht jetzt ja alles es
schaffen das 80% des Stroms und mehr
Strom als heute schon 2030 also in knapp
7 Jahren aus der neue bahnquellen stammt
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass dazu das
Stromnetz entsprechend ausgebaut sein
wird und muss wenn wir davon ausgehen
dass wir gleichzeitig investieren zum
Beispiel die Erzeugungskapazitäten für
Strom mit Gaskraftwerken die auch mit
Wasserstoff betrieben werden können und
da bringen wir die Dinge jetzt auf den
Weg damit das in den 30er Jahren der
Fall ist wenn wir davon ausgehen dass es
Milliarden schwere Investitionen der
Stahlindustrie der Chemieindustrie gibt
um die Wirtschaft umzustellen von
fossilen Ressourcen auf erneuerbare
Energien dann ist das alles was un
mittelbar auch neue Beschäftigung
ermöglicht in Deutschland an vielen
Stellen damit dann dort in den Fabriken
gewerkelt gehämmert und sonst was werden
kann und das werden wir dann auch in den
Wachstumszahlen spüren
der Bundeskanzler hat ja einen leitend
gesagt dass er begrüßt dass ich so viele
Leute Gedanken die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
des Standorts machen das begrüße ich
auch ausdrücklich und das ist ja eine
nicht abschließende Aufforderung gewesen
ja Bundeskanzler ich wollte eigentlich
auch noch nach den Schalldämpfern Fragen
aber das haben sie ja schon beantwortet
deswegen die Frage ob ähm in Sachen
Taurus Debatte Marshall Körper Lieferung
sich vielleicht jetzt bei der Klausur
noch ein Stimmungsbild innerhalb des
Kabinetts ergeben hat es gibt ja von den
Lindner die Äußerungen und dass er
gewisse Sympathien für eine Lieferung
hätte es gibt immer wieder Meldungen
jetzt Front Durchbrüche seitens der
Ukraine bei der gegen Offensive und es
gibt auch die Rechnung seitens der
Ukraine anfangen kommenden Jahres mit F
16 Kampfjets da Einsätze fliegen zu
können wenn sie rechtzeitig entscheiden
ob dann deutschlandkörper mit diesen
Jets zum Einkommen Einsatz kommen können
oder nicht
sie haben ja festgestellt dass die
Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen und Bürger ganz
anders als der ein oder andere der im
öffentlichen Bereich Fragen stellt sehr
einverstanden ist mit der abwägenden
sorgfältig alle Fragestellungen
bedenkenden Politik der Bundesregierung
wenn überzeugt dass nur weil wir es so
gemacht haben wie wir es gemacht haben
und auch weitermachen werden dass wir
uns jede einzelne Entscheidung sehr
schwer machen und dass wir nicht auf
Zuruf entscheiden sondern wenn wir
finden da ist was zu sagen zu tun dass
das der Grund ist warum es unverändert
eine große Unterstützung für die Politik
gibt die Ukraine finanziell aber auch
mit Waffen zu unterstützen und die
Wahrheit ist auch deutschland ist nach
den USA der zweitgrößte Lieferant und
mit dem was wir tun und was wir weiter
tun und wofür wir auch finanzielle
Vorsorge getroffen haben tun wir genau
das was jetzt wie sie eben selbst gesagt
haben unmittelbar wirksam ist also es
geht um unsere Panzer unsere Munition
unsere Artillerie es geht um unseren
Möglichkeiten mit der Luftverteidigung
ermöglichen mit dem Flakpanzer Gepard
mit
irishi wo wir ein sehr spezielles sehr
erfolgreiches Produkt aus Deutschland
dass wir selbst in Deutschland noch gar
nicht einsetzen in der Ukraine
zur Verfügung stellen das gilt für die
Patriots wo wir immer wieder neu
geliefert haben und genau in diesen
Bereichen Artillerie Munition und
Luftverteidigung werden wir auch weiter
unsere Schwerpunkte sehen
ja Herr Bundeskanzler ich habe eine
frage zu Inflation das ist ja in letzter
Zeit nicht mehr so ein Riesenthema
gewesen weil die erleichtert
abgeschwächt ist nun gibt es aber zum
Beispiel in NRW glaube ich im August
doch wieder einen leichten Anstieg wie
sehen Sie das hoffen sie da auf einer
Änderung noch der Politik der EZB sehen
Sie die Gefahr gebannt eine Inflation in
Deutschland oder ist das nach wie vor
ein Thema dass sie beschäftigt
Inflation ist etwas das nicht gut ist
für die Volkswirtschaft nicht gut ist
für die Wachstumsperspektiven und die
Zuversicht nicht gut ist für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und die
Unternehmen die mit hohen Preisen
konfrontiert sind deshalb ist es richtig
und findet auch die uneingeschränkte
Unterstützung der unabhängigen
Entscheidung der Europäischen
Zentralbank durch die Bundesregierung
dass wir sagen
das hat jetzt eine große Priorität und
dass die Zentralbank Entscheidung trifft
die die Inflation zurückführen sollen
ist richtig im Interesse der
Geldwertstabilität der Zukunftsfähigkeit
Europas aber auch der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger unter Unternehmen und das müssen
wir bisher auch Bedenken bei den
Maßnahmen die wir zur
Wirtschaftsförderung ergreifen dass die
so zielgerichtet und so präzise
entwickelt sind dass das nicht zu einem
neuen Inflationsschub führt sondern das
ist nur dazu beiträgt Wachstum anzuregen
also wenn wir mit der degressiven
Abfahrt für die Bauwirtschaft zum
Beispiel erstmal hinkriegen würden dass
alle die ihre baugenehmung haben sich
jetzt einfach entscheiden das zu machen
damit Sie davon profitieren können darum
ist es auch bewusst befristig dann würde
das schon Wachstumsprozesse auslösen
ohne dass das unmittelbar Preis tragen
wäre das gleiche gilt für die
Unterstützung von
Investitionsentscheidungen Unternehmen
durch die Receiver auch das haben wir
sehr zielgerichtet gemacht damit wir
eben keinen eigenständigen
inflationseffekt auslösen und ansonsten
beobachten wir dass wir genau ein großer
Teil der Inflation ist ja zustande
gekommen durch die höheren
energieimportpreise die wir zu bezahlen
hatten das ist deshalb gut dass jetzt
gerade die Meldung eingehen dass diese
Preise erstens zurückgegangen sind und
dass wir auch darauf setzen können dass
das so bleibt und dass sie vielleicht
auch weiter zurückgehen wir gucken mal
wie das ist gerade ich hatte es von
berichtet heute ist berichtet worden
dass die
Importpreise die wir bezahlen müssen
erheblich eingebrochen sind das klingt
immer wie so eine Katastrophenmeldung ob
es ja eine gute Meldung bezahlen weniger
für das gleiche und das ist das was dann
auch ein Beitrag zum Rückgang der
Inflation leisten kann
dankeschön
das Bild der Ampel ist ja weiterhin
schlecht in der Öffentlichkeit und das
liegt vielleicht gar nicht nur in der
Regierung sondern auch in den Fraktionen
ich würde interessieren inwieweit sie
glauben dass ihre Schalldämpfer auch
dort wirken da gab es ja nicht nur in
der Vergangenheit so das Gesetze als
Atombombe für dieses Land bezeichnet
werden sondern jetzt ganz frisch auch
wieder die Kinder Grundsicherung die sie
für die sie eine Einigung verkündet
haben dann als Sozialklimbim bezeichnet
wurde aus der FDP-Fraktion und so weiter
gleichzeitig auch der Streit mit der
SPD-Fraktion über industriestrompreis
also glauben Sie dass Sie da auch da was
verändern müssten und sind Sie
optimistisch dass sie solche Stimmen
eingefangen kriegen erstmal glaube ich
das auch bei den Fraktionen die gleiche
Vorstellung herrscht wie bei uns nämlich
dass die doch sehr erfolgreiche
Leistungsbilanz nicht dadurch
unbesichtigt bleibt weil gewissermaßen
der Weg zur
Findung der Entscheidung so laut ist das
ist ja doch das Merkwürdige ist es viel
mehr entschieden worden als in den
letzten Jahren in einem unglaublich zum
Tempo und ohne diese Entscheidung wen
wir weder durch die wirtschaftliche
Krise gekommen die mit dem Stopp der
russischen Gas und Kohle und Öllieferung
verbunden gewesen sein hätte können
sondern wir wären auch nicht in der Lage
gewesen die grundlegende Modernisierung
unseres Landes voranzutreiben um dies
uns ja geht denn wenn wir eine
Volkswirtschaft sein wollen die in 10 20
30 Jahren noch gute Arbeitsplätze hat
technologisch an der Spitze der Welt ist
selbst wenn da dann 10 Milliarden
Menschen leben
dann müssen wir das jetzt tun das können
wir nicht im Jahre 2014 feststellen dass
wir jetzt was hätten machen müssen
manches war liegen geblieben und deshalb
ist es auch so ein Kraftakt dass auf den
Weg zu bringen ich will das noch mal an
dem Beispiel der Energie sagen ja sind
ausgestiegend zweimal in Deutschland aus
der Nutzung der nuklear Energie am
Anfang des Jahrtausends in der Regierung
Schröder Fischer dann der nach einem
gegenteiligen Beschluss erneut in einer
schwarz-gelben Koalition bei Frau Merkel
nach dem Reaktor Unglück in Fukushima
und wir sind ausgestiegen aus der Kohle
Verstromung
Fahrt bis 2038 und gleichzeitig sind wir
nirgendwo mit dem notwendigen Tempo
eingestiegen was den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien in unserer
Stromnetze was die Frage betrifft dass
wir dann auch eine Struktur brauchen die
sicherstellt dass wir 24 Stunden am Tag
sieben Tage die Woche Strom bekommen das
geht dann ja nicht nur mit
Windkraftanlagen und Solaranlagen und
Biomasseanlagen und Wasserkraft sondern
dann brauchen wir eben auch für den
Rückhalt in speziellen Situationen die
vom Minister auf den Weg gebrachten
gastkraftwerke die mit Wasserstoff
betrieben werden können gleiche gilt für
die Entscheidung die jetzt unmittelbar
bevorsteht wo wir die Gesetzgebung auf
den Weg gebracht haben mit den
Investoren über eine schwere
milliardeninvestition für viele
Jahrzehnte reden über den Aufbau eines
wasserstoffnetzes das muss jetzt
entschieden werden und daran sind wir
mit Hochdruck dran damit das passiert
wir haben schon mehrfach konferiert mit
denen die heute im Wesentlichen die
Gasleitung
betreiben wir ändern das Gesetz damit
die Bundesnetzagentur Gas und
Wasserstoff Netz zusammenbringen kann
solches Tempo haben wir entfaltet und
wenn man das alles sagt dann hat man
genug zu sagen und muss sich nicht
streiten
ach schauen Sie die Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen hat Vorschläge unterbreitet
wie sie das wirtschaftliche Wachstum
stärken will die Fraktion der SPD hat
gesagt sie wolle sich noch sehr genau
die Kinder Grundsicherung ansehen die
das Kabinett beschlossen hat so haben
die Fraktionen eben den Freiraum und
auch vielleicht das Recht ihre autonome
Position kennt zu zeichnen zu
kennzeichnen und auch eigene politische
Projekte auf den Weg zu bringen das ist
normal in der Demokratie viel bei Ihrer
Frage allerdings auf dass sie sozusagen
recht einfarbig war und deshalb habe ich
mir erlaubt jetzt zwei andere Farben
hinzuzufügen
hallo für RTLs neue guten Tag meine
Frage wäre nun wirken sie ja in ihren
Äußerungen hinsichtlich der Politik
schon als wenn Sie eine sehr positive
Bilanz derzeit ziehen gleichzeitig ist
das Stimmungsbild in der Bevölkerung ja
eher negativ geprägt wie nehmen sie das
war wie erklären Sie sich diese
Diskrepanz glaube ich kann für alle hier
sagen die Leistungsbilanz ist gut ich
habe ein bisschen versucht zu erläutern
wie viel und mit welchem Tempo wir auf
den Weg gebracht haben gerade jetzt auch
in der Sommerpause sind eben viele der
notwendigen Vorhaben abgeschlossen
worden so dass jetzt die Gesetzgebung im
Bundestag und Bundesrat beginnen kann
und wir alle haben natürlich den Auftrag
nicht durch die Art und Weise wie wir
uns darum bemühen so viel so schnell auf
den Weg zu bringen
übersehen zu lassen dass wir genau das
getan haben und dieses Vorhaben das so
zu machen dass alle davon auch überzeugt
sind und das Erkennen das haben wir hier
alle noch mal bekräftigt
in der Bevölkerung halt dann doch eher
negativ ausfällt also da ist dann ja
unterschiedlich ich habe eigentlich die
Antwort auf die Frage gegeben
zwei Fragen wenn Sie erlauben einmal der
Tenor auf hier zehn Punkte
Wachstumsprogramm ist ja recht einhellig
alles nicht schlecht geht in die
richtige Richtung aber da muss mehr
kommen noch sagen sowohl Ökonomen als
auch große globale Investoren die
Eurozone investieren und sie selbst der
Bundeskanzler haben ja auch gesagt
Wirtschaft soll jetzt an
Arbeitsschwerpunkt der nächsten Monate
werden jetzt nach der Sommerpause also
endet heute ja nicht dass wenn ihr das
ihrer sich die nächsten unmittelbaren
Schritte um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
Deutschlands zu stärken und die zweite
Frage an den habe ich sie haben ihrem
eingangstatement die Bedeutung der
Klimapolitik betont ist das dann ein
gutes Zeichen dass der neue
klimakommissar mit den höchstens jemand
werden soll der von Klimapolitik jetzt
bislang eher nicht so ganz viel Ahnung
hat muss mal so zu formulieren sondern
eher auf dem Feld der Außenpolitik war
der Mann war auch Finanzminister wenn
ich das sagen darf und den kenne ich
ganz gut das ist ein sehr netter und der
kluger Kollege gewesen damals und ich
bin überzeugt dass er seine Arbeit sehr
gut machen wird dass das für den
Minister habe ich genauso Geld
was die Frage betrifft
für uns ist das ein wichtiger
Schwerpunkt und dass alle das im Großen
und Ganzen gut finden dass wir machen
wie sie berichtet haben ist ja schon mal
ein gutes Zeichen dass der eine und der
andere dann sagt ja und noch viel mehr
noch viel mehr und ganz unspezifisch das
gehört irgendwie dazu die eigentliche
Botschaft ist ganz gut gelungen und das
ist ja vielleicht das was man dann auch
festhalten kann wir werden natürlich
dranbleiben und da geht es aber vor
allem auch um modernisierungsfragen die
für unsere Volkswirtschaft von aller
größter Bedeutung sind deshalb ist es
nicht zufällig so dass wir die Fragen
von Digitalisierung und künstlicher
Intelligenz zum Beispiel hier sehr
zentral verhandelt haben und das muss
auch und wird auch für unsere
Volkswirtschaft von größter Bedeutung
sein ich will das noch mal aufgreifen
künstliche Intelligenz wo wir jetzt hier
sehr umfassend diskutiert haben ist ja
in der Tat eine große Veränderung der
Art und Weise wie wir in bestimmten
Bereichen arbeiten werden es wird uns
große neue Möglichkeiten schaffen und
wir werden das auch in den öffentlichen
Verwaltung im großen Umfang einsetzen
können deshalb war das eine wichtige
Sache wenn es uns gelingt die
ivkraft die darin liegt auch für unsere
Volkswirtschaft nutzbar zu machen die
Tatsache dass es in Deutschland 500
Startups gibt die sich mit dieser Frage
beschäftigen das ist große Unternehmen
gibt die das im Umfang großem Umfang tun
und wenn das als Technologie die auch in
Deutschland entwickelt und eingesetzt
wird haben dann wird das für die
Stabilität und Zukunftsfähigkeit
Deutschlands von größter Bedeutung sein
auch ein weiteres Thema unserer Klausur
wird ja dann noch viele vollgeschritte
haben nämlich der Bürokratieabbau der ja
viele Facetten hat manchmal geht es
darum dass unnötige Vorschriften die das
Leben von Bürgern und Bürgern und
Unternehmen schwerer machen abzuschaffen
das tun wir hier und wir haben ja auch
heute diskutiert dass wir das auch mit
einer europäischen Initiative begleiten
wollen weil ein großer Teil der
Regulierung über die sich die
mittelständische Wirtschaft aber auch
die großen Unternehmen beklagen die
keinen Sinn machen sondern einfach so
gewachsen sind ja auch aus Brüsseler
Feder stammt und deshalb gehen wir damit
beide in beide Richtungen vor und es
wird dann weiter darum gehen dass wir so
wie wir das die ganze Zeit letztes Jahr
und dieses Jahr schon gemacht haben wir
mit vielen gesetzlichen Entscheidungen
dazu beitragen das Entscheidung
schneller kommen können also der Boom
den wir jetzt bei Windkraft und
Solaranlagen haben die Beschleunigung
die wir beim Netzausbau haben
die wären ja nicht möglich ohne die
Gesetze die wir gemacht haben es darf
eben nicht sechs Jahre dauern sondern es
reicht wenn es ein paar Monate dauert
bis eine Windkraftanlage genehmigt ist
und das möglich zu machen ist dann auch
von größter Bedeutung oder es beklagen
sich viele Unternehmen bei uns dass ihre
fertigen Anlagen nicht angeschlossen
werden von den lokalen Netzbetreibern
auch da werden wir etwas machen müssen
damit das mit Tempo kommt das kann ja
nicht sein dass die Dinger da schon
stehen und das Unternehmen von den
Solaranlagen auf dem eigenen
fabriktracht profitieren will aber denn
die Auskunft bekommt dreiviertel Jahr
später kommt der Netzanschluss das muss
ich ändern und zu den
modernisierungspotenzial gehört ja auch
unsere begleitenden Tätigkeit etwa wenn
es um die Elektromobilität geht die so
wichtig ist es ist sehr gut dass die
deutschen Unternehmen so weit
vorangekommen sind dass sie weltweit
websbewerbsfähig Elektrofahrzeuge
anbieten können und das auch tun mit
wachsendem Erfolg aber wir müssen jetzt
natürlich alles dafür tun dass der Tempo
beim Ausbau der Lade Infrastruktur das
Tempo stimmt und auch dazu werden wir
noch weitere Entscheidung treffen die
vorbereitet sind also wir bleiben am
Thema Tempo Beschleunigung
Bürokratieabbau an dran und glauben dass
das auch ein eigenes Wachstumspotenzial
für Deutschland enthalten kann
große Frage Tobias Peter
Herr Minister Lindner gibt es aus ihrer
Sicht Dinge im Koalitionsvertrag die
jetzt hinten angestellt werden müssen
die man vielleicht nicht mehr machen
kann weil sie sagen wir müssen uns jetzt
erstmal drauf konzentrieren aus dieser
wirtschaftlichen Krise rauszukommen oder
kann alles abgearbeitet werden auch an
sonstigen Projekten und Herr
Bundeskanzler inwieweit ist sind sie mit
der ampelregierung bereit sich daran zu
messen daran messen zu lassen ob das
Land aus der wirtschaftlichen Krise
rauskommt also würden sie sich im
Zweifel den Satz so eigen machen wenn
uns das nicht gelingt haben wir es nicht
verdient wieder gewählt zu werden oder
sagen Sie es gibt eben so viele
Parameter die wir gar nicht im Griff
haben dass man sich da nicht festlegen
kann
Peter alle Vorhaben des
Koalitionsvertrages sind
gleichberechtigt wir haben die Absicht
zu viel wie möglich umzusetzen davon es
ist dann immer eine Frage der
Konkretisierung und des Timings es gibt
Vorhaben die kann man schneller umsetzen
weil vielleicht auch finanzielles
Volumen da ist und es gibt andere die
können nur auf den Weg gebracht aber
noch nicht vollständig abgeschlossen
werden das ist jeweils immer eine Frage
des Einzelnen Projektes richtig ist
unsere finanziellen Spielräume sind eng
nehmen sie nur alleine die jüngste
Entscheidung
oder die jüngste Entwicklung beim
Bürgergeld wir hatten eine Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes ja bereits geplant findet
sich im Finanzplan für 24 und 25
sie ist aufgrund der allgemeinen
Preisentwicklung jetzt höher ausgefallen
als die ursprüngliche veranschlagerung
also haben wir wieder Mittel die wir
erstmal finden müssen die dann nicht zur
Verfügung stehen für Neues sondern für
die Ausfinanzierung von bestehen aber
das ist das übliche Geschäft
wir werden das hinbekommen dass wir mit
den Impulsen die wir setzen die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung Deutschlands
voranbringen und wir haben ja auch
ausgezeichnete Bedingungen dafür das
Problem von dem wir stehen ist ja nicht
wie Anfang der Jahrtausendwende dass wir
eine hohe Arbeitslosigkeit haben und
viele die Zuversicht verloren hatten
dass die sich ändert jetzt werden wir
von lange für lange Zeit darum bringen
müssen dass wir genügend Arbeitskräfte
bekommen das aber können wir auch
hinkriegen denn mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz und den jetzt
folgenden Maßnahmen für eine möglichst
unbürokratische Umsetzung werden wir
genau das tun was die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft braucht nämlich ihr die
nötigen Arbeitskräfte
zu führen wenn man das so sagen kann
damit Wachstum auch tatsächlich
stattfinden kann also das ist eine
lösbare Herausforderung und genau und
die haben wir uns schon an die Aufgabe
muss schon angemacht
und dann zum Abschluss Matthias reich
meine Frage errichtet sich zunächst an
den Bundeskanzler dann bitte auch an die
beiden Minister und es geht um ein Thema
was gerade in diesen Tagen auch viele
beschäftigt der Bayerische Rundfunk die
Sendung Report München hat mit einem
ehemaligen Mitschüler von Hubert
Aiwanger gesprochen der sich öffentlich
und nicht anonymisiert äußert und er
berichtet vor allem Hitlergruß aiwangers
beim Betreten des Klassenzimmers und von
judenwitzen zu diesen Witzen gibt es
heute offenbar eine weitere
eidesstattliche Erklärung eines anderen
Zeugen wie bewerten Sie diese Aussagen
und was sollte Ihrer Meinung nach jetzt
passieren danke schön
alles das was bisher an bekannt geworden
ist ist sehr bedrücken und deshalb ist
für mich sehr klar dass alles aufgeklärt
werden muss und das wenn das geschehen
ist was das ist und auch nichts
vertuscht und verwischt wird dann
natürlich auch die notwendigen
Konsequenzen daraus gezogen werden
müssen
ich finde den Umgang den Umgang mit den
Berichten von Herrn eiwanger
unaufrichtig
und vor allem
hat der Aiwanger ja in
verschiedenen Redebeiträgen
offensichtlich in der jüngsten
Vergangenheit
eine Sprache des rechten Populismus
benutzt insofern geht die Frage finde
ich an den Ministerpräsidenten des
Freistaats Bayern ob er mit einem
Kollegen der so agiert weiter in Zukunft
zusammenarbeiten will ich finde es
schwer vorstellbar
in Deutschland darf es niemals Platz für
Antisemitismus geben das ist der
demokratische Grundkonsens er darf auf
keinen Fall relativiert werden die
Vorwürfe gegen Herrn Aiwanger sind
bestürzend und der Umgang und die
aufklärungsbereitschaft sind in meinen
Augen bislang nicht glaubwürdig und
deshalb muss hier dringend Klarheit
geschaffen werden mit denen dann
gegebenenfalls notwendigen Konsequenzen
die er selber ziehen muss oder der
bayerische Regierungschef
bedanken
schönen Dank tschüss
wir haben gehört die Pressekonferenz von
Kanzler Scholz Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck Finanzminister Lindner was
passiert beschlossen wurde ein
sogenanntes
wachstumsschancengesetz und jetzt nach
den Fragen der Journalistinnen und
Journalisten haben wir auch Zeit für
eure Fragen ich fass kurz zusammen also
was bedeutet das wachstumschancengesetz
Steuererleichterung für die Wirtschaft
außerdem geht's auch um ein
Eckpunktepapier zum Bürokratieabbau auch
das wurde beschlossen das werden wir
gleich für euch genauer erklären was
nicht passiert ist es gab keine
Positionierung zum industriestrompreis
und auch darum wird es gleich gehen und
auch darum wie die drei wie die Ampel
wie die Koalition hier Geschlossenheit
demonstrieren wollte all das wird uns
jetzt einschätzen können unser
Hauptstadtstudio Korrespondent dominik
chefka ist wieder bei mir schön dass du
da bist Dominik hallo Alisa
wir hatten kurz darüber gesprochen nur
hat das kurz darüber gesprochen bevor es
dann sogar Schluss gegenüber das
sogenannte Wachstumschancen gesetzt wir
haben eine kleine Grafik schon mal kurz
zusammen drauf was bedeutet das
eigentlich es geht als das sogenannte
wachstumschancengesetz soll Unternehmen
von insgesamt sieben Milliarden Euro
entlasten jährlich bis 2028 eine Prämie
in Höhe von 15% soll Investitionen in
den Klimaschutz belohnen für den Bau
neuer Wohngebäude sind massive
Steuererleichterungen geplant
hat uns der Kollege das sogar
netterweise erklärt ich muss das gar
nicht tun also wir haben es gehört und
die Wirtschaft die ist geritt kritisch
die war im Vorfeld kritisch auch jetzt
wieder gibt es schon kritische Töne nach
der Pressekonferenz der Wirtschaft ist
das nicht genug sie wollte mehr
Entlastung aber Lindner will die
Schuldenbremse einhalten aber nach der
Kritik es gab ja jetzt ein neuen Entwurf
was ist neu was wie ist das
einzuschätzen was da vorliegt neu ist
das ist dann doch ein bisschen mehr Geld
wurde also ganz zu Anfang haben wir von
ungefähr 6,6 Milliarden Euro gesprochen
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
weniger 6 Milliarden so die Kante jetzt
sind also ungefähr 7 Milliarden Euro es
gibt ein paar die sagen möglicherweise
es gab ja so ein Veto von Lisa Pause von
der Familienministerin weil das zwei
Wochen aufgehalten wurde so sagt es
Christian Lindner selbst konnte man noch
ein paar Verbesserungen so nennt er das
reinschreiben diese sieben Milliarden
Euro bedeutet zum Beispiel dass die
Unternehmen Dinge leichter abschreiben
können das hat Christian Lindner einmal
so ein bisschen kryptisch gesagt
degressiver AfA also Absetzung für
Abnutzung bedeutet das um das mal zu
übersetzen ein Unternehmen kauft ein
Kopierer der Kopierer geht vielleicht
zehn Jahre und man kann in jedes Jahr
abschreiben absetzen das soll einfacher
funktionieren also so gesehen ist dieses
Paket noch mal ein bisschen größer
geworden aber völlig richtig es gibt
genug aus der Wirtschaft die heute schon
sagen das reicht immer noch nicht bei
den Grünen zum Beispiel gibt es diese
Stimmen auch denn außerdem heute Thema
wir machen Kommentar dazu bei uns im
Stream von User germain der schreibt bei
Youtube oftmals wird das Stichwort
Digitalisierung im Zuge des
Bürokratieabbau genannt Implementierung
von digitalen Infrastrukturen heißt
zunächst mehr Bürokratie bitte um
Einschätzung und jetzt gibt's da eben
ein Eckpunktepapier für den
Bürokratieabbau was kannst du uns dazu
einschätzen damit vielleicht muss ich
erstmal sagen der hat der Nutzer nicht
ganz unrecht wenn man jetzt das
Kindergeld z.B vereinfachen möchte dass
er die andere große Form die sich die
Ampel vorgenommen hat dann muss man das
ja irgendwie zentral ausbezahlen und da
gibt's ganz massive Kritik das bei den
Ämtern das ganz schön schwierig sein
wird also das ist nicht ganz falsch aber
dieses Eckpunkte Papier von Herrn
Buschmann von dem du gerade gesprochen
hast das hat damit jetzt zunächst mal
nichts zu tun da geht es darum dass die
Wirtschaft mit 2,3 Milliarden Euro
entlastet wird für weniger Bürokratie
die Sie machen müssen Beispiel ist das
hat Herr Buschmann heute morgen auch
schon gesagt wenn man ins Hotel
eincheckt muss man immer noch auf Papier
den Meldeschein ausführen das soll bald
künftig nicht mehr sein man kann den
Mietvertrag offenbar bald elektronisch
kündigen also man schreibt eine Mail
dass man den Mietvertrag kündigen möchte
oder auch Buchungsbelege unternehmen
müssen die ganz oft zehn Jahre lang
aufrecht erhalten und irgendwo im
Schrank sammeln dass man also noch 10
Jahren gucken kann wann hat man vor zehn
Jahren mal jemanden zum Essen eingeladen
Geschäftsessen das muss man vielleicht
bald nur noch acht Jahre aufbewahren
also das sind insgesamt die Bürokratie
abbauideen die Herr Buschmann heute
vorgestellt hat 28 sind insgesamt
und dann was heute kein Thema war das
ist ja auch interessante
industriestrompreis da wurde ja in den
letzten Tagen auch schon immer wieder
über das für und wieder diskutiert worum
geht es da die Senkung der Strompreise
für energieintensive Industrie und da
kam heute keine Positionierung warum
nicht da kam heute keine Positionierung
weil es ein Konflikt gibt in der Ampel
das war gerade ein bisschen schwammig
das wurde gerade so ein bisschen
verschwobelt auf der Pressekonferenz
selbstverständlich gibt es dort einen
Konflikt also man stelle sich vor man
bezahlt 13 Cent pro Kilowattstunde für
den Strom aber große Unternehmen wie die
Wirtschaft wie die Stahlindustrie z.B
brauchen sehr viel Strom für die soll
das künftig vielleicht nur noch fünf
oder sechs Cent pro Kilowattstunde
Kosten diesen Unterschied diese Lücke
muss ja irgendjemand Zahlen vielleicht
der Staat vielleicht Subventionen eben
vielleicht wir alle und da sind die
Grünen dafür dass die FDP dagegen und da
ist die SPD auch eher dafür aber der
Kanzler oder Scholz dagegen das hat er
so deutlich gerade nicht gesagt
aber diesen Konflikt kann er nicht weg
diskutieren da gibt es im Augenblick
keine Einigung und deswegen gerade auch
keine Entscheidung und keine Verkündung
und Stichwort keine Einigung das gab es
ja bei so vielen Themen jetzt auch in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten was immer
wieder heute betont wurde wurden auch so
so Begriffe aus dem Handwerk bemüht wir
sind eine Regierung wo gehämmert
geschraubt wird aber es kommt auch etwas
raus immer wieder wurde das betont man
wollte sich da also so tatkräftig zeigen
nachdem man sich ja in der Vergangenheit
jetzt uneinig war gerade zuletzt eben
auch bei diesem wachstumschancengesetz
das hätte ja schon vor zwei Wochen
eigentlich beschlossen werden können hat
sich aber die grüne Familienministerin
dagegen gestanden immer wieder gibt es
da diese fragen für was wird Geld
ausgegeben wer bekommt welches und heute
also wieder ganz klar hat man sich
hingestellt und gezeigt man ist einig
oder wie würdest du das bewerten
das ist politische Folklore das ist das
was jetzt geschrieben werden soll das
sind die Überschriften die sie im
Prinzip den Journalistinnen und
Journalisten in die Notizblöcke und in
die Laptops diktieren wollen es wird
gehämmert es wird geschraubt was hat
Herr Scholz gesagt die Schalldämpfer
müssen rausgeholt werden Herr harberg
hat von Laubsäge Arbeiten gesprochen es
kann nicht verdecken dass es Konflikte
gibt in dieser Ampel das
wachstumschancengesetz die Kinder
Grundsicherung die Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes das sind Konflikte in
dieser Ampel und die kann man nicht
durch diese Folklore übertünchen die
Konflikte sind nicht gelöst die Stimmung
ist manchmal wirklich schlecht das merkt
man auch hinter den Kulissen auch bei
den Grünen sind einige nicht ganz sicher
was Frau Poster eigentlich gemacht hat
ob dieses Veto strategisch so schlau war
und das jetzt versuchen wollen zu
überdecken mit solchen witzigen Bildern
ich finde das funktioniert nicht und
gibst du uns zum Schluss auch noch mal
ein Fahrplan wie geht's jetzt weiter
wenn es da zum einen also jetzt so ein
Eckpunkte Papier gibt wenn es jetzt ein
beschlossenes Gesetz gibt wie geht's
ganz praktisch weiter Sommerpause ist ja
jetzt bald vorbei das hat der Kanzler ja
gesagt dass angeblicher die
Bundesregierung die Sommerpause genutzt
habe und das eben jetzt der
parlamentarische Betrieb kommen möge das
Gesetz das von Herrn Lindner jetzt
eingebracht wurde das wurde heute
verabschiedet es wurden auch noch ein
paar andere Gesetze verabschiedet von
Herrn Lauterbach zum Beispiel zu
elektronischen Patientenakte diese
Gesetze gehen jetzt den
parlamentarischen Weg also zum Beispiel
Anhörung im Bundestag Debatten im
Bundestag dann muss der Bundestag
irgendwann zustimmen und verabschieden
das ganze das wird jetzt mit diesem
Gesetzen passieren dass Eckpunktepapier
von Herrn Buschmann der Bürokratieabbau
ist noch kein Gesetzesentwurf also da
muss er Buschmann noch ein Gesetzentwurf
draus machen bevor der in den
parlamentarischen Prozess kommt also so
gesehen das sind zum Teil noch vorhaben
die erst noch umgesetzt werden müssen
und dabei vielleicht eben auch noch
Änderungen erfahren werden
Einschätzung von Dominik schepker
unserem Hauptstadtstudio Korrespondenten
vielen Dank Dominik sehr gerne und wir
haben uns jetzt weil heute Wirtschaft
natürlich auch das große alles
überschreibende thema war auch wenn wir
natürlich bei der Pressekonferenz auch
immer wieder andere Themen die angetippt
wurden gehört haben wir wollen aber
jetzt noch mal ganz intensiv auf die
wirtschaftlichen Sorgen hier in
Deutschland eingehen und ihr könnt dazu
nach wie vor Fragen stellen wir haben
uns einen Wirtschaftsexperten eingeladen
Peter Rasenberger vom Think Tank
grantiro es bei uns er beschäftigt sich
intensiv mit der Frage wie die soziale
Marktwirtschaft den Wandel in das 21
Jahrhundert überleben kann und auch wie
sich eben alte Industriebetriebe neu
aufstellen müssen ist jetzt bei uns
Peter Rasenberger hallo schön guten Tag
vielen Dank schönen guten Tag Herr
Rasenberger sie haben mit uns jetzt hier
auch eine Dreiviertelstunde lang
zugehört da wurde wurden viele Fragen
gestellt an die drei Verantwortlichen
aus der Koalition und reden wir direkt
über das wachstumschancengesetz das
beschlossen wurde ist das jetzt ihrer
Meinung nach der große Wurf
also es wurde ja schon auch von ihren
Kollegen gesagt es ging wohl auch sehr
darum zu zeigen Handlungsfähigkeit zu
präsentieren das Gesetz hätte man locker
vor paar Wochen auch verabschieden
können und wenn Sie Fragen ist das der
große Wurf kann man darauf eine klare
Antwort geben nein das ist nicht der
große Wurf die Regierung wird schon in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
eingeholt werden von der weiteren
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung wir sind
mitten in Rezession wenn sie nur die
letzten Tage Wochen beobachtet haben was
da jetzt gerade auf dem Immobilienmarkt
passiert dann stehen Sie kurz vor einer
neuen Immobilienkrise allein in den
letzten paar Tagen ist mehr
Immobilienvermögen in die Insolvenz
gerutscht als die sieben Milliarden
dieses wachstumspakets
es ist klar
es soll gezeigt werden dass es jetzt
vorangeht das ist auch glaube ich
wichtig für die Regierung dass sie sich
zusammenfindet dass sie endlich mal
wieder miteinander spricht und auch
versucht irgendetwas von dem was sie auf
den Weg bringen möchte auch
abzuschließen aber dieses 7 Milliarden
Paket wird
und Scholz sprach dann auch heute davon
wie also jetzt durch den Umbau der
Wirtschaft auch mehr Arbeitsplätze
geschaffen werden können mehr Wachstum
geschaffen werden kann sehen Sie dafür
jetzt aber zumindest eine Grund ein
Grundstein gelegt wie schätzen Sie das
ein
also das was sie ja zurzeit erleben ist
ja dass Unternehmen gar nicht mehr zum
Teil in Deutschland investieren wollen
also wir beobachten hunderte von
Unternehmen die Deutschland verlassen
wollen und zwar nicht irgendwann in paar
Monaten sondern es läuft gegenwärtig
gegenwärtig gibt es ein Problem und dass
ich dann
Investitionen besser abschreiben kann
das ist zwar schön und das ist auch
wirksam für mittelständisches
Unternehmen die richtig aber das wird
natürlich nicht reichen die Unternehmen
die sich jetzt ins Ausland verabschieden
oder komplett stillgelegt werden
die werden nicht im Land dadurch
gehalten dass wir irgendwann ein
Kopierer besser abschreiben können
ja sie sind vor allem auch wirklich im
Land unterwegs der sehen sie viel sie
beraten nämlich natürlich auch Firmen
sie erleben auch viele Firmen die es
eben nicht schaffen und wenn jetzt so
ein Papier kommt zum Beispiel zum
Bürokratie Abbau was ja natürlich auch
vielen vielen Firmen und Unternehmen
helfen soll glauben Sie das kommt jetzt
auch schon zu spät schätzen sie das
pessimistisch ein optimistisch
ich bin grundoptimistisch und zwar immer
grundoptimistisch alles was dort gesagt
wurde hätte man schon längst machen
können Schwamm drüber es ist gut wenn
das was dort jetzt angekündigt wird auch
gemacht wird letztendlich wirkt es etwas
niedlich wenn sie im Kern Bürokratie
abbauen wollen muss man doch erkennen
dass wir in einem Land leben das mehr
Gesetze hat als jedes andere Land auf
diesem Planeten wir haben auch mehr
Steuergesetze als jedes andere Land auf
diesen Planeten stellen sich vor diese
ampelregierung müsste für jedes Gesetz
was sie jetzt neu hinzufügen wollen ein
anderes Gesetz streichen
was dann da los wäre hätten die richtig
was zu tun ich nenne das manchmal so
eine Buchstaben Diät stellen sich vor
die jetzige Verordnung hat irgendwie
1000 Buchstaben diese neu machen wollen
und dafür müssten sie an anderer Stelle
ja das gleiche Ministerium an anderer
Stelle 1.200 Buchstaben also 20% mehr
einsparen damit würden sie im Bürokratie
Abbau hinbekommen ob sie sich im Hotel
anmelden müssen und meldescheinauswahl
ausfüllen müssen verstanden das ist nett
habe ich gestern auch gemacht das geht
auch und dass das völlig überholt ist
ist auch klar aber ich glaube
gegenwärtig soll der Eindruck erweckt
werden der wird viel Bürokratie abgebaut
es gibt lohnenswertere Ziele als
Meldescheine fragen Sie mal jung
Unternehmer was sie in Deutschland
machen müssen wenn sie Unternehmen
gründen wollen ähm ich war wieder in den
letzten Wochen in der Lage a ein
Unternehmen in Irland zu gründen und B1
in Deutschland in Irland waren
Unternehmen Gründungsakt inklusive
Eintragung in 24 Stunden erledigt
in Deutschland sind sich nach zwei
Monaten immer noch nicht sicher ob es
geklappt hat ja im Einzelfall also
dazwischen liegen Welten
die Themen wurden alle gesagt auch vom
Bundeskanzler wurden sie alle gesagt
dass das alles schneller gehen muss
ich glaube wir sprechen über völlig
andere Dimensionen wenn wir in der
Wirtschaft sprechen und deswegen ist es
auch so verständlich dass einzelne sagen
er ist ja mein Anfang nehmen Sie das
Beispiel was er gesagt hat wir brauchen
in Deutschland um ein Windrad
von der Idee bis zur ersten
Kilowattstunde
durchzubringen rund sechs Jahre und
dass die Regierung an bestimmten Punkten
gezeigt hat tatsächlich gezeigt hat zum
Beispiel bei den Terminals dass sie
Genehmigungsprozesse halbieren kann wir
reden nicht davon etwas statt in sechs
Jahren in drei Jahren zu machen
wenn sie das ernst meinen mit dem
Klimawandel wenn sie das ernst meinen
mit der Energiewende dann müssen wir
runter auf 90 Tage vielleicht noch
weniger ja also wir reden über Faktor 10
und gleichzeitig im Tagesgeschäft werden
sie von Gericht noch gefragt wie in ihre
Faxnummer ist und ob Sie
wie Sie irgendwelche formalakte machen
können ob sie nicht lieber vorbeikommen
und irgendwas abzuholen das in einer
digitalisierten Welt also da klappt viel
auseinander
es geht aber nicht um eine pauschale
Kritik Bürokratie abzubauen ist absolut
richtig das bisschen wird nicht reichen
da wird man richtig ernsthaft
reinschauen müssen und ich glaube der
erste Punkt über dem man ernsthaft
diskutieren muss ist Abbau von Gesetzen
ja also wenn Steuergesetze so
umfangreich sind in Deutschland dass ihr
Leben nicht mehr ausreichen wird alle
Gesetze diese befolgen müssen zu lesen
dann hat der Kaiser keine Kleider machen
und dort sind wir angekommen ja das
heißt wir müssen ein sehr grundsätzliche
Thema
grundsätzliche Themen und das was sie
das gezieren also natürlich von Jahren
auf 90 Tage da liegen in wirklich
dazwischen ja noch Welten es gibt hier
einen User Paul Müller bei uns bei
Youtube der stellt der Regierung da aber
in zumindest diesen Punkt auch ein
positives Zeugnis aus weil er fragt
nämlich was ist denn mit Intel im
Saarland und TSM sie in Dresden die
kommen wegen der Deals der Regierung
sind die besten Chip Hersteller der Welt
okay das finde ich gut auch ein gutes
Stichwort weil sie zwei sehr
unterschiedliche Chip Hersteller genannt
haben
und die es geht mir nicht um
Einzelkritik an Unternehmen diese beiden
Unternehmen sind überhaupt nicht
vergleichbar also während das eine
ein Weltmarktführer ist der mit
herausragendem Produkten in die Zukunft
schaut hat man gleichzeitig eine Insel
nach Deutschland geholt wie in der
vordersten Liga gar nicht mehr mitspielt
das ist eine Öffentlichkeit so nicht
ganz klar wahrscheinlich ist das dem
Politikern auch nicht ganz klar aber nur
ein Unternehmen zu holen weil der Chip
drauf steht ist in der Wirtschaft
mit großer Skepsis aufgenommen worden
und beide dies sind nicht gleich beide
Dinge die dort gemacht sind sind nicht
vergleichbar aber sie haben in der Tat
ein Weltklasse Unternehmen der
Vergangenheit ein historienunternehmen
ins Land geholt und ein Weltklasse
Unternehmen der Gegenwart und Zukunft
beides in einem Satz geht kaum aber dazu
ist tatsächlich Wissen in der Chip
Industrie notwendig um das einzuschätzen
sprechen Sie uns auch noch mal werden es
mit Dominik chapter ja auch schon
angerissen Richtung Ende mal noch über
ein Thema was eben heute kein Thema war
über den industriestrompreis dazu hat
man sich nicht positioniert gibt aber
auch viel Diskussion darüber wie sehen
Sie das dass man sich da also jetzt
nicht festgelegt hat
ich glaube sogar dass es gut ist dass
man sich nicht festgelegt hat weil es
aus meiner Sicht als Ökonom
gar nicht möglich ist als ein
Nationalstaat von der Größe der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gegen den
weltweiten Energiemarkt zu wetten das
geht nicht gut es gibt keinen Betrag der
groß genug ist das durchzuhalten
warum hat man das trotzdem vorgeschlagen
das war sicherlich auch gut überlegt
weil man ein Pflaster auch die Situation
tun möchte momentan ist eben Strom für
bestimmte Unternehmen
zu teuer bestimmt Unternehmen werden aus
dem Markt aussteigen aber viel besser
wäre es eben in der Tat sich klar zu
machen dass die der Wohlstand in
Deutschland
daran hängt wie viel Strom wir
verbrauchen können
zu glauben dass man durch Strom
einsparen in irgendeiner Form die Wände
hinbekommen wird ist irrig wir werden
sehr viel mehr Strom pro Kopf brauchen
und je mehr wir Strom pro Kopf
verbrauchen können desto höher wird
unser Wohlstand sein also muss das Ziel
doch sein so viel Strom wie nur irgend
möglich zu produzieren dezentral das zu
produzieren und jedes Hemmnis was es
dort gibt Windräder hatte ich schon
gesagt ja also von sechs Jahren auf 90
Tage runter ähm an jedem Ort mehr Strom
zu produzieren dann wenn das Angebot
steigt die Nachfrage sich so entwickelt
wie es vorausgesagt wurde fällt der
Strompreis und dort können Sie nicht nur
ein bisschen mehr machen sie könnten
hundertfach mehr machen und das ist viel
zu zaghaft aus meiner Sicht
nehmen Sie mal die vielen 100
Quadratkilometer an Dachflächen die
mittelständische Unternehmen haben
da kleinere Anreize jetzt zu schaffen
wenn sie dort in erneuerbaren Energien
investieren
das wird nicht reichen ja und wir fahren
wenn Sie den mal fahren Bezügen ein ICE
dessen Außenflächen eben nicht Solar
beklebt sind wir stehen auf Autobahnen
wo LKWs sind dessen Dächer nicht
Solarflächen sind wir bauen Autos in
Deutschland sehr gute Autos dessen
Dächer eben keine Solarflächen sind wir
haben unendlich viel Platz um
solarzumachen denken Sie nur mal was
rechts und links von der Schiene am
Bahnsteig ist wir müssen viel viel mehr
Strom produzieren wir müssen die
Weltklasse Technologien die wir in
Deutschland haben und Strom in
Wasserstoff zu wandeln und rückzuwandeln
da gibt es tatsächlich Startups auf die
die Welt schaut in Deutschland also als
Deutschland extrem stark
die müssen wir in die Breite bekommen
und auch produktmäßig in die Breite
bekommen und wir müssen das
überlandlinien und Strom zwischen
Bundesländern hin und her schicken zu
können endlich beenden und wir können
nicht auf jeden Bürger Prozess ähm
Protest Rücksicht nehmen die Klarheit
muss es dort geben der Kanzler hat
gesagt wer bei ihm Führung bestellt
bekommt sie geliefert es wird Zeit das
zu liefern
und zuletzt aber noch die Frage an Sie
weil ich habe das jetzt ein paar mal
noch im streamen gelesen da fragt sich
zum Beispiel ein User das gäbe immer nur
Entlastung für die großen Unternehmen
die haben doch schon genug warum soll
nur die Industrie billigen Strom
bekommen jemand anders fragt sich wieso
werden nur Unternehmen niemals
Privathaushalte entlastet sehen Sie da
auch zu wenig Entlastung für jetzt
Privathaushalte BürgerInnen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger
es gibt grundsätzlich ein Problem in
Deutschland das historisch gewachsen ist
und dass man auch groß und anders denken
könnte also fangen wir mal mit den
Unternehmen an die Frage ist sollten wir
nicht ein anderes Wirtschaftsministerium
haben ganz sachlich und zwar ein
Wirtschaftsministerium dass ich aufteilt
in ein Industrieministerium dass ich um
die klassische klassische Vorstellung
von Wirtschaft die große Unternehmen
kümmert und ein zweites Ministerium
vielleicht mit einem eigenen Minister
die sich um Unternehmer und die
Mittelstand gemacht
und klar ist Deutschland hängt am
Mittelstand aber der Mittelstand hat
eine nicht annähernd so große Lobby wie
die Großunternehmen dieses
Ungleichgewicht begleitet uns seit
Jahrzehnten das ist auch bekannt und
wahrscheinlich funktioniert das nur wenn
man das irgendwann beginnt aufzuteilen
und zu sagen die Priorität die wir nach
außen verkaufen die Startups haben
sollen die der Familienunternehmer haben
soll
die bilden wir jetzt auch mal im
Kabinett ab und die bilden wir auch bei
dem Parlament ab und die bilden wir
einen anderen Stellen der Demokratie an
die Frage ob wir zunächst uns um die
Entlastung der Unternehmen kümmern
müssen und oder zunächst um die Bürger
die ist volkswirtschaftlich schnell zu
beantworten wenn wir jetzt die Weichen
nicht richtig stellen bei den
Unternehmen stellt sich gar nicht mehr
die Frage ob wir Bürger entlasten können
weil das Geld dafür nicht da sein wird
Einschätzung von Wirtschaftsexperte
Peter Rasenberger vielen Dank dass Sie
sich heute Zeit für uns genommen haben
herzlichen Dank
und ich habe gerade noch mal die Zeit
auch genutzt in eure Kommentare kurz zu
schauen Sie auch dass da unzufriedene
Töne natürlich stehen insgesamt mit der
Bundesregierung so schreibt Thorsten
graue bei Facebook die SPD ist
eingeschlafen die Grünen machen alles
nur noch schlimmer und die FDP nickt
alles ab und wir haben jetzt die
Möglichkeit mit jemanden mit einem
Politikwissenschaftler darüber zu
sprechen was diese Unzufriedenheit auch
für Auswirkungen habt hat und wie sich
das niederschlägt vor allem auch im
Osten Deutschlands denn wir haben uns
eingeladen Politikwissenschaftler Julia
nekhoff er hat gemeinsam mit der
Volkshochschule und der Hochschule
Zittau Görlitz eine spannende Befragung
durchgeführt ich erzähle gleich mehr
darüber sagt aber erstmal hallo schön
dass Sie da sind
ich darf ganz kurz sagen was sie da
spannen das gemacht haben denn so habe
ich das auch noch nie gehört und wir
können also gleich darüber sprechen also
sie haben in Görlitz eine Befragung
durchgeführt wo eben die Unzufriedenheit
mit der Ampel sehr groß ist in Görlitz
und eben auch die Zustimmung zu AFD sehr
hoch sie haben sich also damit
beschäftigt was ärgert die Menschen was
beschäftigt sie warum wenden Sie sich
von der Regierung ab und getroffen haben
sie die Menschen dort wo man ja
bekanntlichermaßen ziemlich frei weg von
der Leber spricht und zwar in Görlitzer
Kneipen hallo
das stimmt ja das ist völlig richtig und
jetzt sind wir natürlich sind wir
natürlich sehr gespannt auf diese
Ergebnisse sie haben ja eben gerade auch
hier mit uns schon sehr lange zugehört
der Pressekonferenz selbst Minister
Habeck hat ja von einer
krisenerschöpfung gesprochen hat die
also eingeräumt haben Sie das auch so
gehört von den Menschen mit denen sie
gesprochen haben Görlitz
also mein neues totes Merkel müde glaube
ich wir merken wie du geworden
das ist eine ganz neue Tempo jetzt was
gar nicht kennen so von der Regierung
und wir glauben jetzt
vorwärts gehen
fortschrittskoalition jeder hat da
technische Spruch alle Dutzend sich alle
glauben miteinander reden zu können zu
verschiedenen Geschichten
aber das haben wir gar nicht so erlebt
eine Befragung es war ganz anders es
gibt eine Unsicherheit der Menschen
ich habe das immer so gesagt also 80
Prozent der Menschen schätzen sich als
hätten sich eigentlich als Sicherheit
haben auch kein Problem mit Geld mit mit
einer Krise eigentlich ja eigentlich da
sein sollte die wir alle auch jeden Tag
in den Medien hören aber wenn man sich
fragt ob es in anderen Menschen gut geht
dann sagen sie nein ich glaube nicht
dass es anderen Menschen gut geht das
halten doch quasi von 5 Häusern sagen
vier fünf Menschen mir geht's gut aber
dem anderen muss sehr schlecht gehen und
das ist ja deswegen so verrückt weil
genau das Problem also wir haben viele
Worte gehört
Schalldämpfer alles Mögliche was
interessant ist aber im Endeffekt möchte
es ja etwas bewirken etwas injizieren
nämlich
und ob sie wirklich arbeitet das können
wir ja
einschätzen es gibt viele gesetzent
versucht einzusparen
Bürokratieabbau wird ständig in den Mund
genommen der eine möchte investieren
dann er möchte Geld sparen aber im
Endeffekt ist es doch so dass wir merken
dass die Leute gar nicht also es ist
doch verrückt dass die Menschen die
ganze Zeit das Gefühl haben oh Gott oh
Gott was passiert jetzt also Herr
Lindner Herr Buschmann kümmert sich um
einen Unterhalt auf Haus möchte jetzt
irgendwelche Begriffe neu definieren
Kindergeld und so und die Menschen sind
noch mitten im krisenmodus gewonnen hat
gerade genau Ukraine gibt es auch schon
mittlerweile fast anderthalb Jahre und
Sie fragen sich einfach wann ist mal
Ruhe dabei möchte die
fortschrittkoalition keine Ruhe sondern
Bewegung weil ich der Meinung bin und
das zeigen auch die Umfragen 70 % der
Menschen möchten die Ampel nicht mehr
haben oder zumindest nicht mehr ein
gutes Handeln zu und aktuell
Sonntagsfrage stehen sie bei 40% etwa
aber es soll immer weitergehen wir haben
noch zwei Jahre Zeit immer schneller
immer mehr Gesetze Gesetze Gesetze die
dann meistens aber natürlich abgebremst
oder auch relativiert werden auch nicht
so in in den Gesetzentwurf gegossen
werden müsste also wir haben ein Problem
von Wahrnehmung und wirklichen handeln
was da passiert ich sehe kein Hermann
und klopfen ich sehe Schleifen auch so
ein
wenn du selber vielleicht zu
restaurieren
gerade in der Pressekonferenz auf die
Frage warum in der Bevölkerung die
Arbeit der Regierung so schlecht
wahrgenommen wird geantwortet er findet
die Leistungsbilanz ist gut trotzdem die
Frage an Sie wir haben es ja eben gerade
auch schon angesprochen in Görlitz sind
eben die Werte für die Ampel nicht
besonders gut für oder die Ampel
Parteien für die AFD hingegen sehr hoch
erreicht die Menschen mit denen sie
gesprochen haben überhaupt das über dass
sie Ampel da diskutiert oder welche
Themen stehen da eigentlich im Fokus
wir haben das Mikrokosmos und
Makrokosmos genannt Nico Kosmos also
Arbeit Familie Freizeit eigene
Gesundheit und Makrokosmos also
Flüchtlingsbewegungen
Wirtschaftskrise Inflation Ukraine Krieg
was die Menschen erreicht ist das was
ihm persönlichen Leben und das was ich
auch erleben tatsächlich beeinflusst das
war bei Corona ja nur die sichtbar habe
verschiedene
ja Ausgangssperren so umgeimpfte wir
haben verschiedene Maßnahmen die halt
eingestellt haben die Menschen sehr sehr
sensible drauf reagiert aber wenn wir
fragen ob die Menschen aktuell
eingestellt sind was sie tun trotzdem
teuren Preise ich meine ähm ich bin nie
meine Vergleich der Stolz war nicht ganz
sicher der Bundeskanzler was ähm und
Butter kostet
Tomaten zum Beispiel aktuell
3,99 €, 4,99 5,99 nachdem geht das merkt
die Menschen schon aber es ist trotzdem
so dass die Menschen das noch aushalten
und sagen jetzt geht es noch aber ich
warte auf schlechtere Zeiten und das ist
ja dass das ganze Stolz zumindest habe
eben nicht vermitteln wollen sondern es
wird alles viel besser wir müssen nur
ein bisschen warten noch und alles so
gut und ähm ganz gut aus
finde ich und aber trotzdem ist es ja so
also auf der einen Seite fragen wir uns
jedes Mal wo ist er denn zwei drei
Wochen dann sagt er war Arbeiten erste
modus operandi wenn er sich dann einmal
über zweimal innerhalb von wenigen Tagen
äußert warum redet also
wir haben ganz anderes Problem nämlich
wir haben eine empörungs- und eine
erregungskrise der Menschen also jeden
Tag merken sie es gibt irgendein Problem
sie lesen das auch bei Social Media sie
wissen das auch im Internet aber es ist
auch im Fernsehen wir haben Krise Krise
Krise und die Menschen sind müde von der
Krise zu ähnlich gesagt aber da hinten
ist nicht einfach zu sagen alles wird
bald besser weil vor allem in
Ostdeutschland wissen wir ja oder wir
kennen den Spruch
warte mal ab die Bühne Landschaften und
die Fälle wurden ja nicht immer ganz gut
bestellt muss ich sagen
Kommentare bei uns bei Youtube von
Daniel Straßen zum Beispiel er schreibt
tut die Ampel zu wenig die eindeutige
Antwort ist die Ampel tut so viel mit
dem Tempo gibt es bis zur nächsten Wahl
nichts mehr was ich zu retten lohnt so
die Meinung hier von Daniel Schraven
jetzt wollen wir auch gerne noch mal mit
ihnen darüber sprechen die
Zustimmungswerte für die AFD eben in
Görlitz besonders hoch insgesamt in
Sachsen besonders hoch warum ist die AFD
dort die beste Alternative
weil sie die Menschen vor dem
Mikrokosmos schützt also die AFD sagt
kümmert euch nicht um den Klimawandel
wir wissen nicht genau ob der wirklich
Menschen gemacht ist ob uns das
einschränken müssen wir wollen raus aus
der Ukraine keine Waffen liefern damit
hat sich das Thema erledigt wir wollen
Grenzkontrollen deswegen kommen nie
wieder Flüchtlinge zumindestens auch das
Sprechen
jetzt beim sommerinterview
also das Problem ist die Menschen
glauben dass die AFD in die Probleme die
wir sowieso alle erleben werden
und damit kann ich normal weiterleben
ich kann also gehen ich kann im Urlaub
buchen da brauche ich auch keine Sorgen
machen Flugzeug ist oder ob das ein
Kreuzfahrt ist kein Problem die AFD sagt
ja ich kümmere mich um euch und das
erwähnt ihr uns aber es ist ein
toxischer abstürmer sage ich mal die AFD
weiß natürlich die Probleme nicht löst
sondern nur verlagert und sie haben
kleine redet das kommt bei der Menschen
gut an weil sie das ja auch kennen also
ich habe damit merken immer gesagt ich
glaube der ist ganz treffen die Menschen
kennen das Tempo nicht und ähm der User
hat recht der Kollege wenn er sagt es
geht ganz schnell alles also wir sind
wieder in diesem Ferienmodus wir wollen
noch zwei Jahre etwas erreichen was
bewegen wir wollen auch so eine Bilanz
auch haben bei am Ende müssen sie auch
2025 zumindest mal im Januar Februar
März wenn so langsam der Wahlkampf
anläuft wieder mal sagen was sie alles
geschafft haben aber wie der Kollege
Rasenberger gesagt hat alles zaghaft
alles sehr
kompromissorientiert aber kein
Durchschlag und ich glaube wir müssen
die Menschen nennen mitnehmen auf so
einer wilde
fortschrittkoalitionsfahrt müssen wir
noch mehr fordern und da müssen sie
vielleicht auch gewöhnen und zum Schluss
dann noch die Frage an Sie warum
erreicht also die Ampel dann doch die
Menschen dort so schlecht und wie könnte
sie das besser machen haben sie dazu
auch Erkenntnisse bekommen ja
es ist ganz einfach die Menschen reden
nie über den Bürgermeister benannt hat
immer über in Lauterbach der schlechte
Zähne hat und stolz irgendwie bei
unterwegs ist habe das Kinderbuchautoren
ist nicht bekannt dass bei
cannabisministerium Kinderbuchautoren
arbeiten müssen also Wirtschaftsexperten
in der Ministerialbürokratie aber das
bringt nicht durch zu den Leuten ja also
die Leute glauben immer
Politik funktioniert am grünen Tisch so
wir reden miteinander zack wird
beschlossen weg aber es sind die
auszahlungsprozesse hinter den Kulissen
also wir müssen mit den Menschen mehr
reden wir haben das bei Corona versäumt
ich habe das mal die
Pandemie der Kommunikation oder
kommunikationspandemie genannt also dort
schon haben wir nicht erklärt was ist
los ein Problem mit den ganzen Gesetzen
das machen warum müssen wir manchmal
auch Entscheidungen treffen die wir
vielleicht später bereuen erinnert
wahrscheinlich mal alle bald miteinander
und
gegeneinander sich entschuldigen aber
das Problem ist denke ich dass die Leute
erklärt haben wollen was passiert und
ähm ich nicht also ich sehe gut
ist jetzt ein Handwerker und Herr
Lindner steht
bezüglich dessen was er immer sagt einer
gewissen
Absolution weil er ja über das Geld
entscheidet und ich glaube die Menschen
können das nicht ertragen und die
Menschen finden es arrogant
in sich in einem Punkt möchte ich gerade
schon sagen ist technischment angestellt
und die da oben erklär mir nichts wollen
meine Privatsphäre Eingreifen ich
bestrafen dafür und will ja
ein Schatz sagen sie den letzten Satz
nochmal ich habe es nicht gehört
also
keine Wahl aber die sehen ja dass die
Ergebnisse der der sonntagsverfahren
allerlei wirbeln Berlin machen aber
keiner so richtig inhaltlich versucht
die AFD auch
das sagt Julia neckowski
Politikwissenschaftler aus Görlitz
vielen Dank dass Sie heute bei uns zu
Gast war ich danke Ihnen
und es gibt auch schon erste Reaktionen
auf das Wachstumschancen gesetzt zum
Beispiel hier von der CDU
cdu-schiff-chef Friedrich Merz hat sich
also geäußert sagt sagte dass der Bund
für das sogenannte
wachstumschancengesetz die Zustimmung
der Länder nicht bekommen wird so
prognostiziert er das der Bund hätte
eine bessere Möglichkeit eine Entlastung
für Mittelstand und Industrie zu
realisieren sagt März er könnte sofort
den Soli abschaffen also da wurde sich
zwar gerade zum einen auf etwas
verständigt und gleichzeitig folgt auf
dem Fuße die Kritik das Thema wird uns
also noch weiter beschäftigen für heute
nach dieser langen Sendung erstmal
vielen Dank für alle die bis zum Ende
hier mit dabei waren für eure fragen
Kommentare bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss